like now what I spend most of my time on
is calibrating what I know people are
going to do but trying to figure out the
time in one of the practicality of
timing well let's start off this episode
properly
happy birthday Misha I love you so much
seven years old I can't believe it time
flies my little princess look at the
best yo-yo sir go
and I'm like we got to figure out a room
in the house to like put some of the
stuff boy do I love the house yeah it's
the best and what's going on where's my
team candy yeah I really want to talk
about video Andy the share bear is not
being implemented in edit so for you to
I don't care how much you hate it
it's learnings for me I don't care if
it's like you've got the hippest
[ __ ] it's like dirt [ __ ] Street
hip-hop and now that [ __ ] bear comes
in the last 13 seconds it makes no sense
guys telling right now like here's the
funny part you have to listen to me not
the other way around
so sometimes sometimes you guys feel
like you can sneak through some
liberties and you think you're doing
your own thing and I find it very cute
and I laugh and I'm like oh that's nice
and all that but then I can get mad too
and so on that I want the [ __ ] share
bear and every video that comes out for
the next month I just want to see it
guys this is Jordan hey
Jordan's Mike we got a PS say hello meet
everybody one by one
Stefan good Zach Zach good Andy good
Brittany great Andrew good okay guys get
it d-roc here we go all right now Jordan
run it back I'm getting good it's okay
so guys like this Britney Britney it's
okay Andrew and d-roc all right look
Andy friggin andrew dear good
so Mike great always just watching you
on vlog yesterday is that right yeah how
are you I'm real good man what's your
name Jamel nice to meet you man that's
the point I figure I'm always welcome
honestly I'm like it one day I'm gonna
it's today's a day I'm sitting around
Thomas Windham yes
so repledge mezack i wish you well thank
you yeah she's just like it's hard to
get too high for a presence when just
you get a lot of them like ice like
freak for like one wrestling figure you
know for yeah but just different we
rented that sometimes just hard you know
like you can't fake environment you just
can't we can artificially fake it you
know good time with you oh yeah and
that'll be like but that's more
foundational subconscious stuff that's
later on you know she isn't she only
realize what you yeah yeah
open the window no
boy
you guys working yeah all right so
what's going on so we are on our way to
the meet future food competition and so
for two hours we're gonna sit there and
have teams pitches yeah so teams are
gonna pitch you and then each judge is
going to have the opportunity to ask
questions immediately after that team's
pitch before going on to the next team
so I just see the team's
I like this format to be fun to see what
they they bring to the table
I will I owe it every time I do this
kind of stuff I go in very blind because
I feel like I feel like my I never want
preconceived notions I want to be fair
to the teams
yeah I might I believe in the pitch
I'm also usually fine my like first
reactions are always better so I go in I
have no idea I don't know anything when
you do the jumping jacks
how does even know that you did the
technology element is it an app or when
you say we what is the team but
everybody had potentially has that
infrastructure now right you're far more
likely to be discovered if you wrote
your article on invite you know
environmental impacts on obesity both in
childhood and in the workplace on medium
than if you did it on your own blog
because nobody knows your own blog is
this you guys thought about making it a
slack bot first thank you thanks for
your time
the thing that I think really stands out
for me as this collective group and I
think it's something I believe in
tremendously is I think way too many
people spend way too much time on their
shortcomings or the things that if they
think they're going to be weak at I
think this collective group as I sum it
up as a unit what what's very obvious to
me is for you guys to triple down on
your strengths when I look at anything
about picnic when you're looking up
their business that has happiness at its
core like there's a lot of things you
could be doing but quadrupling down on
that is something I think all of us need
and I think all of you if you look at it
you break down from your backgrounds or
day jobs right now have a core strengths
and I think you get a lot of advice from
a lot of people and all the things
you're not and I think when you really
look at the companies that are
succeeding they close all that noise out
and they
Drupal go all the way down under text
ranks under understanding so that's what
I would say that's what Congrats
thank you Raji thank you a couple years
ago though
hey I am male on I'm male on one of
knobbies people how are you continued
success brother we run into each other
again Marcus I gotta run away thank you
see you soon okay
you know expand a little bit on the of
what you saw in there about the timing
thing I'm very fascinated by that now
what I spend most of my time on is
calibrating what I know people are going
to do but trying to figure out the
timing it's just it's it's predicting
behavior and predicting its timing and
hitting that cross-section and that is
extremely difficult and that's why the
people that do it tremendously win and
get movies made about them and make lots
of money and like live their dream
because it's that rare to actually know
that I think so many people have great
ideas but they so lack the ability to
understand consumer behavior and the
macro trends and what's happening in
society timing is everything
timing is you know you hear that all the
time and of course like every absolute
standpoint like hustle is everything
like talent is everything like
everything is everything until you
realize using a food analogy it's if
you're a great chef you can take all the
ingredients and make something great
it'd be great if all the ingredients
refresher better you know higher quality
but if you're a great chef you can even
take second and third tier foods and
make a better meal than somebody who has
given all those great ingredients so of
course talent and timing and intuition
and and hustle and all those things are
imperative but everything is imperative
you know they're all a mix there's so
many variables and success but timing
happens to be one of them one of them
that I don't talk a whole lot about so
it was fun to kind of a jam on that a
little bit as I'm sitting here thinking
about it it it really makes this whole
journey of daily be super worth it to me
right like here we are episode 40 I
believe the timing is important I've
learned from timing but with all the
keynotes with all the articles with you
following me around for 40 days worth of
content now here it is and that to me in
a weird way is why I have ambition and
hopes and dreams for daily be because I
recognize how many things are deeply in
here that don't populate that they go
through ABS and flows that also becomes
a thing self-awareness has become a
thing lately right patience becomes a
thing
but what are the seven to twelve 1529
other things that are deeply ingrained
in here that I take for granted that I
haven't been able to figure out how to
populate from there to here to there to
here that's a that's a challenge and a
journey that I'm excited to continue one
of the I'm practicality in timing well I
mean that goes into that goes into the
talent of recognizing moments you know
and that's so challenging like I don't
know how to like I don't know how to
like teach people to seize the moment
when they see a white space I believe
the Facebook video is you know under
under used by most so we have a meeting
today I'm like let's go like let's go we
need to pump out micro [ __ ] 1/2
minute videos 2/3 a day on Facebook we
will win it is working it works my
ability my to recognize things that are
about to happen you know there's no
different than then a filmmaker who
knows how to make the movies he or she
knows how to make the movies of the time
right or or music like who are the
people that understood that hip hop or
EDM was about the pop or talent agents
who are like you're a superstar there's
there's a intangible that is very
difficult to articulate on why I
understand that people are gonna be all
in on snapchat I think about the things
that I know that you're going to do that
you think you're not and you don't think
that you're gonna be on snapchat and I
know you're going to be badges I can't
articulate it other than the radar goes
off and and I'm starting to learn that I
got to be more aggressive when the radar
goes off and go harder stronger meaner
um and that's that
you